we are going to play a man-machine match
which we call brains versus AI where we
are bringing in four of the top human
specialists in heads-up No Limit Texas
Hold'em to play against the top AI which
is a librettos Poker has a central role
in the history of game theory the
classic challenge problems like or sale
of checkers chess go they have all been
games where AI has surpassed the best
human chess very famously the blue beat
Garry Kasparov in 1997 and computers
have been better than human to that game
ever since just last year alphago
famously beat one of the world champions
and go and this was a major milestone in
AI so there's been a lot of success in
these perfect information games
real-world situations
deal with hitting information deal with
uncertainty that's the kind of situation
that poker you know really represent
Limit Texas Hold'em was actually near
optimal it sold in 2015 while No Limit
Texas Hold'em is much harder and it
actually turns out to be the last
frontier in a way at least the last
frontier in the foreseeable horizon of
game solving in AI so if you try to take
alpha go and have a play poker they want
to know how to bluff it would be very
easy to beat and that's because a game
let go on a game like poker are
fundamentally different when you
introduce this element of uncertainty it
changes the dynamic completely this
uncertainty is what we're addressing
with liberties and it's something that's
unique to the algorithms that were using
we will be playing twenty days
and overall we will be playing one
hundred and twenty thousand hands of
Poker there are lots of applications
because most real-world situations are
games of incomplete information
these include negotiation as a consumer
level and business-to-business
cybersecurity and medical treatment
planning for example one of the goals of
AI is to arrive at something called a
general artificial intelligence this is
an AI that can address any situation
that it runs into not just a specific
domain like go or poker if the field of
AI is going to achieve this goal of
general artificial intelligence it needs
to be able to address this problem of
uncertainty which comes up a lot in real
life
we see these algorithms that are being
used in this but is really advancing the
field for those problems how do you how
do you deal with uncertainty in the real
world
[Music]